[Music]
uh he would like a hot soup not cold
we'll show you that uh Ramsay's head
[Music]
what happened with the soup I have a
thermometer here boiling hot you want to
check wanna check with me it wasn't
boiled in half and now you see it it's
boiling hot yeah it is but when it went
out it was before you you guys send
something up please check double check
triple check check one more time yes yes
listen go to your bar
[Music]
sorry about that don't worry just when I
went to taste these These are so salty I
mean you'd need six Mojitos before you
start eating six spoons of that all
right they're disgusting excuse me let
me take this back
what a shame we couldn't even get the
basics right do me a favor please try
the beans Marcelo try the means
[Music]
holy crap
God
they're definitely definitely a lack of
Harmony in the kitchen
[Music]
do it do it do it do it now I want this
one right now
oh my God there's gonna be a complete
disaster
now my kitchen go all over my kitchen
now
how you doing yeah fine thank you and
you I'm fine can I get you anything else
while you're waiting no I'm gonna wait
for the clap here okay okay thank you I
hope it comes all right thank you very
much
I know I can't believe it
the basic of us
I hope you enjoy it because it's
actually my favorite dish thank you
[Music]
delicious wow
you love it yeah he loves it
[Music]
the fish is not cooked
ah it's really nice
that is a shame I'm gonna bring it back
that's a very big mistake on behalf of
the kitchen
[Music]
Notch cooked
raw fish wrong with you guys
wrong
[Applause]
[Music]
goodbye
my name is Julie I'll be your server
this evening gentlemen have you decided
I really don't know something Danish
obviously the grandfather duck remember
the wiener system please working in
before wine Denny's chicken and winners
I need Cindy please
just 30 minutes into service and a
number of entrees have left the kitchen
Perfection that's what you got dinner's
ready so clearly speed is not a problem
at Fleming
they're pretty awful
however satisfying customers is
[Music]
so good
thank you
so she said it was very Bland
let's put it this way we won't be coming
back
I couldn't even look at that Anita
it's thick and Bland you blend to land
yeah it just doesn't taste very good
okay I let him know 53 hated this one
okay okay what didn't he like about this
you just said he hated it he said he
can't eat it
I'll bring you the menu ma'am so you can
choose something else and I'll get you
another picnoli salad thank you
oh no come on this is mushy Andy is
absolutely afraid of change he's tried
to keep the tradition and I think it's
time to move on
it's a Non-Stop parade of food being
returned to the kitchen you know that
yes almost everything coming back was
Bland doesn't taste well doesn't tastes
good what's going on with it
no flavor
flavors
oh [__] those dishes were all Danish
style items that have been there for 25
years can I get you something else to
eat you're just eating bread that's not
gonna help chicken was totally Bland I
don't see how anything can get worse at
this point while Andy tries to pacify
unhappy diners I can make something like
uh coconut shrimp very quickly crab
cakes Chef Ramsay has seen enough for
the kitchen in action he's heard the
complaints about the food and knows that
many of the problems are not caused by
cooking alone
but by what is lurking in the storage
unit
oh
mashed potatoes piping hot this is
unbelievable Andy Suzanne come in here
[Music]
I think I just chipped my tooth
like Duck cartilage Christ show him the
bone as well Jesus
that's my tooth yeah man he found their
bones
it doesn't go away go away he doesn't
listen to nobody that's it that's the
way he is can I change the handy all
right
Jesus coconut curry jalapeno my God
garlic coconut lamb inside the it is
okay did you show Chef for college yeah
I did he uh told me to be like go go
away did you want to talk about it
that's the truth
[Music]
so rubbery huh the texture of the Lamb
was just very rubbery
Mediterranean crispy fried lamb Curry
roll
I'm in Florida not in Mumbai
whatever this is [__] this is just
to clock us up no that's not why
whatever I'd stop right there if I'll
even go away
Gordon Ramsay trashed everything they
did I think that's his whole goal is to
trample all over you make you feel bad
okay uh right that was interesting so
that was you at your best I wasn't my
best I've ever done in my career he made
the best here or do you mean is that the
best food we have yes or no I mean was
that I asked you to cook for me and yeah
just tell me how that was for you
that was good for this restaurant it's
good for here
[Music]
no problem
food's old-fashioned and totally totally
out of text in terms of where you are
that's your opinion
the food is sad stuck in the 80s
possibly the most shocking Dish anywhere
in Florida the crispy lamb roll what in
the hell was going on when we put that
one together tready coconut horrible
rubbery texture almost on the verge of
being depressing
[Music]
many more you want to put me down for
briette I don't know if anyone give you
feedback but it was one of those are
breaking my tooth all right I'm supposed
to believe that you're not looking at me
now as if I'm exaggerating was full of
cartilage I'm listening to what you're
saying nobody I didn't know no one told
me no one told you
bonus doesn't work
do you not tell the chef that the first
mouthful was full of cartilage
yeah I did yeah I told him he told me to
go away when your wife it comes to tell
you valuable information you should know
those kind of things right
can I just have two minutes with Andy my
own would you mind Ellen would you mind
honestly yeah straight up I'm here to
help so far all you're doing is just
slam me down that's all you've done with
me I think it's about you blame me I
know yeah
it's not my chef it's not we don't work
for him you're the chef owner right
so why won't you take responsibility I'm
the chef you don't like it that's fine
it's your opinion you don't like it
we're [__] we're no good I'm lousy
whatever
[__] me do you have issues this looks
like a [__] up version of a science
lab thank you you're welcome wow
salmon is dry
and overcooked
[Music]
awesome
do they Pace that together in the
morning and stick it together slice it
just now and is it salmon fresh or is
that Frozen
um I couldn't tell you to be honest
would you ask her because it tastes
Frozen okay let me go ask thank you you
want to know if your Salmon's fresh or
frozen tell them it's fresh but it is
frozen
she said the salmon comes in fresh and
then they freeze it
it's like eating a piece of cardboard
there that has to be Florida's worst
dish ever
he said the salmon Divino he said what
tastes like cardboard
here to help me he's not supposed to be
telling me that nothing's good give me
the Snapper Anna if he complains about
this I'm really gonna [__] kick his
ass
and there's the snap arena for you the
Snapper Anna I'm just out of Interest
where is the Snapper we're under all
that under all that
this one looks like a
dog's dinner I don't know how well this
is gonna work
oh my God I just tasted mush
it's mindful nearby I'll get them for
you
um just taste that for me would you I
think that's the Snapper Anna
[Music]
should be baked a little longer all
right
[__] disgusting yes sir
thank you would you do me a favor we
make sure that CeCe tastes that yeah I
think it's really important all right
thank you
what do you saying for you to taste
taste what
the Snapper was soft
what the hell you want it to be a hard
like a rock I mean I don't even get that
tell me you know why the CC doesn't even
want to cook in the rest now I'm really
getting pissed off I'm not kidding she's
going mad does she washes
tell him that I said the starving people
in the world and if I have to keep
making food to go in the garbage I don't
want to make any more right now I want
to bring in the next no right now
damn why should I make him anything else
I don't waste or nothing [__] him
you see sad that there's starving people
in the world
seem to tell me coming
and tell self okay I don't think it's
fair that you
got to tell CeCe when she's finished
cooking she can tell me everything She
Wants until then I'm here to eat and to
taste the food I'd appreciate that okay
thank you so much
I didn't want to tell CeCe the truth at
all about anything he's saying
kill me he's gonna kill the messenger
before she even kills Gordon Ramsay
[Music]
he's saying this later you can tell him
yourself but right now he wants to try
and eat everything
so he is a bigger [__] than I thought
that's [__] him what [__] him [__]
him [__] for friends
[Music]
and which one is the uh that's the
favorite
lovely I don't care how many [__]
stars he has
you can kiss my stars
Jesus I'm so pissed off right now that's
just not nice soggy in the middle and
crispy on the outside it's Dreadful
Bland thank you madam yes take your
knife uh with you I'm not gonna say [__]
I'm just gonna throw it I try to throw
it in the garbage before she saw me
because I knew she was gonna flip
[Music]
to it I was so mad at him I wanted to
represent about him he's British he
doesn't [__] know anything about the
pizza
[Music]